ben si c'est bonjour oui bonjour alors
bonne c'est un surnom je m'appelle
bouillie cissé merci pour cette
précision merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
ce matin sur rtl france le colonel
assimile aux états on le disait prête
donc serment aujourd'hui à bamako à
bamako comme président de la transition
en un mot quelle est l'atmosphère sur
place dans quel état d'esprit sont les
maliens
alors lui la tension est très bonne les
maliens sont toujours en attente de
résultats probants de cette transition
donc je pense que comme il a été dit à
plusieurs reprises il est temps de
rectifier la trajectoire de cette
transition
en huit mois il a aidé dans votre
résulté dans votre dans vos propos
préliminaires et très peu de résultats
en tout cas le constat est qu'il fallait
rectifier la trajectoire de leurs la
transition alors il n'y aura pas
d'ambassadeur 1 pour représenter les
pays de la communauté internationale
mais des observateurs
comment est-ce que ce signal politique
est perçue ou encore une fois je pense
que ce genre de comportement d'une
certaine communauté internationale
permettra aux malades d'être résilient
et de comprendre qu'il faudrait compter
que sur le vin parce que cela s'est
depuis de nous tous nous nous à 2013 en
tout cas nous avons la présence des
forces étrangères
pour quel résultat donc aujourd'hui
compter sur la communauté internationale
c'est très bien mais il est temps que
les manières se donnent la main se
réveille enfin et comprennent que celle
nous maliens nous pouvons et nous devons
régler le problème le propres problèmes
y a des attentes très dense où il ya de
l'espoir il y avait des attentes de la
communauté malienne avec le colonel
hasmig rita oui naturellement et je
pense que ça va au delà de la personne
du colonel de hacine guitare je le
disais tantôt je pense qu'ils les
maliens à un moment donné il y aura ce
sursaut d'orgueil c'est sursaut national
qu'il faut que nous allons venir tous
ensemble et pour les bleus
le chef de l'état présent de la
transition à ses militants pour sortir
le mal et de l'ornière n'attendant rien
de la communauté internationale ci n'est
ni la russie ni la france ou des pays
qui veulent ressembler le mahdi si nous
cessons des partenaires maintenant ils
sont dans des condamnations de principe
mais ces grands pays ces grandes
puissances nous condamnons ça mais les
voleurs du denier public
ces grands pays ces grandes puissances
cette communauté internationale ne
condamne jamais la mode gouvernants le
coup d'état n'est que mais leur cause
nick est en tout cas le résultat de
certaines causes du à la mal gouvernance
alors en tout cas toujours la communauté
internationale qui attendaient des
garanties de la part du colonel à singer
ita et notamment la nomination d'un
premier ministre civil ce sera le cas
vraisemblablement oui je pense que l'on
tend vers slam dans l'avare un premier
ministre des civils j'espère moi
personnellement qui viendra peut-être du
game 5 est quand même la force de
contestation qui a permis aux militaires
du parti mais c'est ce combat populaire
alors le colonel golta qui s'était
engagé sous la pression à une période de
transition limité à 18 mois
et puis conduites par des civils
pourquoi finalement il n'a pas respecté
cet engagement en faisant arrêter le
président et le premier ministre alors
ils allaient 18 mois nous sommes
toujours dans les humains il reste
encore huit mois
donc comme vous l'avez dire il a
respecté que ces engagements ayant un
président un chef de l'état civil
même si c'était un militaire à la
retraite et un premier ministre
mais ces deux personnes visiblement
n'ont pas comblé les attentes et malgré
la feuille de route dégagée pour la
transition dont il fallait à un moment
donné se responsabiliser prendre les
choses en main et afin dé tenir le
calendrier
je rappelle quand même que nous avons
donné un calendrier électoral il
vraisemblement en 2022 en mars 2022 dont
vous voyez
pour l'instant il faut rectifier la
trajectoire mais quand j'aurai bien
rassuré la première en trente secondes
et vos éditeurs le délai pour les
élections
sera maintenu mais le préalable il ya
des choses à mettre en place il ya des
choses à riga qu'est-ce qu'il faut
régler à mettre en place très
concrètement
très concrètement alors je vais pour
votre information nous avons des
nouvelles régions dont il va falloir un
découpage administratif et organiser ces
régions-là permettre d'avoir des
nouvelles circonscriptions électorales
nous la diaspora nous sommes aussi
concernés
nous devons avoir enfin le député à
l'assemblée nationale donc il ya la
question sécuritaire parce qu est ce qu
on va organiser les élections sachant
qu'elle ne peut pas se tenir sur le
territoire national uniquement pour
faire plaisir à la communauté
internationale est le partenaire donc
vrai c'est ce que je disais il ya un
préalable à aller aux élections
l'élection n'est pas une fin en soi même
si c'est l'exigence d'apporter
internationale mais la communauté
internationale devrait d'abord nous
aider à sortir de l'ornière à sécuriser
notre pays vous voyez ce n'est pas que
notre taupe et de malik est unique c'est
le mal et on sait le burkina c'est une
rivière
si la guinée c'est le sénégal vous
l'avez déjà en 48 heures et plus de 180
morts au parquet la face ou est ce un
lien avec la fin des opérations
conjointes avec l'armée malienne de la
part de la france je me posais la
question justement la france a
effectivement été échaudés elle a
suspendu ses opérations communes avec
l'armée malienne vous venez de le
rappeler vous venez de le rappeler
également la situation dans le sahel
elle est préoccupante 180 morts au
burkina faso comment tout cela est perçu
par le colonel hugo et en salle et de
citer un seul responsable si les profs
oculi style et contrairement à ce que
l'on peut le penser n'est pas dans un
jeu anti france au contraire on le
répète la france est un pays partenaire
depuis de nombreuses années mais un
moment donné on s'est posé la question
aussi pourquoi à 6 secondes ses
opérations alors que nous sommes dans
une dans une phase très déterminante
pour cette transition est ce un moyen de
pression
et pourquoi ne pas soutenir cette
tradition enfin et de manière franche
parce que la france dit craindre des
dirigeants maliens qu'ils fassent des
concessions avec des 10
disque quand est-il bon je pense que
comme toute guerre comme tout conflit il
fallait un moment donné négocier la
france a négocié avec les nazis lors de
la seconde guerre mondiale il a fallu
négocier les nazis ton pour enfin aller
vers la paix on ne peut pas après il ya
le temps de la guerre et attendait et de
la paix parmi ces gars disent il ya des
magnans s'ils ne sont pas des renégats
total il reviendra dans le giron malien
donc je pense qu'il ya entre maliens il
faudrait s'asseoir discuter enfin savez
ça fait depuis devenus tous les jeunes
traités les armes crépitent
jusqu'à présent pour quel résultat des
morts des morts et encore des mois
aujourd'hui et nous notamment
l'organisation qui le conseille si parra
de la d'histoire malienne nous nous
sommes toujours battus pour pour tout
enfant a disputé entre maliens et
compris les dia liste merci à vous
monsieur cissé d'avoir répondu à nos
questions dans la matinale de rtl france
je le rappelle vous êtes membre du
conseil national de transition